several mythologies worldwide feature
the mischievous presence of trickster
gods stories and legends about these
deities depict them as they sow chaos
for the pleasure of justifying
conventional behavior well-known
examples include loki from the norse
pantheon or anasi in the west african
and caribbean law the function of these
divine practical jokers is to propel
change to test the cohesion of the
social order or to poke fun at the
contradictions lurking behind an
apparently functioning society when you
imagine these tricksters you more likely
picture them wreaking havoc in a distant
past populated by fantastical creatures
but what if i told you that britain and
ireland had their own tricks to god in
the early 20th century born into high
society he mingled with poets writers
and politicians but he made it his
mission to poke fun at everything and
everybody his elaborate and sometimes
cruel practical jokes raised outcry
scandal and even parliamentary inquiries
this is the story of horusevir cole king
of pranksters patron saint
of april fools day
[Music]
horizon vehicle was born on the 5th of
may 1881 in balincolleg county cork in
today's republic of ireland back then
part of the united kingdom of great
britain and ireland his father was
william cole a rich englishman who had
made a fortune selling quinine a
treatment for malaria his mother was the
anglo-irish aristocrat and poet mary
devire throughout his early years horace
was fascinated by both sides of his
familial heritage he idolized his father
and his down-to-earth practical approach
to life but he was fascinated by the
intellectual milieu frequented by his
mother steeped in celtic and irish
mysticism horace's early years were
generally happy that is until a bout of
diphtheria left him partially death this
disability contributed towards his
social awkwardness and made him
extremely sensitive to the criticism of
his peers the boy could still count on
his father's love and support though the
true bedrock of his childhood
unfortunately when he was just 11 he
received the news that dad william had
died of cholera while on business in
india when mary remarried two years
later horus felt betrayed and rejected
to add insult to injury barely weeks
after his mother's second wedding horus
was shipped off to eaton the pinnacle of
the british public school system which
is public only in name being a private
institution the boy hated this decision
well aware that his deafness put him at
a disadvantage he later wrote why the
devil with such a handicap was i sent to
eaton where no deaf boy could hear
anything in form carla's cruelty i call
it i should have been taught a trade or
profession his school career was largely
lackluster horace enjoyed the lessons
and was rather popular with the other
pupils but he didn't win any prizes
didn't play any sports and didn't hold
any position of responsibility
unsurprisingly he decided to call it
quits shortly before graduating in
february of 1900 horrors left eaton and
like many young men of his generation he
volunteered to fight in the anglo-bar
war in may of that year he landed in
cape town with the distinction of being
the youngest cavalryman in the entire
british army heavy losses in the officer
corps propelled his career and by the
2nd of july he had been promoted to
acting captain on that day while riding
back from a skirmish with the enemy
horace failed to spot a boar sniper
hiding by the road the marksman took aim
and fired landing a direct hit on the
young officer's head so i really hope
you enjoyed today nah
that's just a prank you see what we did
there clever well it appears that
despite the marksmanship of the bar army
surgeons saved horus life but the wound
was too severe and the young coal was
discharged and sent back to britain his
military career had lasted barely three
months leaving him with a campaign medal
a standard army issue moustache and a
pension horace cashed in the entire
pension in a lump sum 1 800 pounds and
in today's money that would be 236 000
pounds or 322 000
displaying remarkable generosity oris
donated the entire amount to the fund
for war widows and orphans after fully
recovering from his wound horos set
about getting a place at cambridge
university with the help of a tutor he
barely secured entry and began his
studies in october of 1902. the fun
times were about to kick off
[Music]
at cambridge horace hung around some
promising students people like future
economist john mayne at keads later a
friend of writer virginia woolf or
leonard future husband of writer
virginia woolf and adrian stephen
current brother virginia woolf obviously
horace cross passed with virginia
herself she would later describe him as
an irishman with beautiful blue eyes and
a little moustache and perfect figure
but more importantly rather a dangerous
friend for a young man to have he was a
wild young man it was a bit of escape
grace horus proved her completely ripe
by joining clubs such as the magpie and
stomp society and the cambridge alpine
club the former was named after a local
brothel and its main pursuit was the
consumption of alcohol the latter was
dedicated to climb in the college rooms
at night and presumably after the
consumption of alcohol the hard partying
student also entertained political
debate having been raised in a
conservative household he quickly
converted to socialism and became a
proponent of the fabian society which
advocated gradual reforms what really
made him stand out however was his love
of pranks some of his stunts were
harmless for example if a friend was
sent down or temporarily expelled he
would stage large fake funerals on the
university grounds on other occasions he
would dress up as a bishop showing up at
schools and churches to perform
confirmations and baptisms other jokes
were particularly cruel once he entered
a friend's room at 3am and woke him up
in terror by shoving a dagger into the
pillow events such as this indicated
that horace had a darker side biographer
martin downer speculates that cole's
passion for practical jokes was a coping
mechanism developed to cope with his
deafness with the death of his father
and with his mother's rejection the
injury suffered in the war and the
subsequent discharge had been the final
trigger this was the last straw which
would set cole in a revenge path against
a world which had left him fatherless
death and crippled by injury so there
was a darker side to the joker cole was
known for sudden bouts of violence and
reckless behavior interspersed with
melancholic spells down or even
conjectured the coal may have suffered
from bipolar disorder according to
contemporaries and especially friend
adrian stephen horace's pranking was
rooted in a disdain of established
authority in adrian's own words the two
agreed that anyone who took up an
attitude of authority over anyone else
was necessarily also someone who offered
everyone else a leg to pull and during
their second year at cambridge horus and
adrian started looking for some serious
legs to pull they were looking for the
perfect joke to humiliate the
establishment the tricksters came up
with an exciting plan dress up as german
soldiers travel to old sass lorraine and
then cross the border into france at the
time the two european powers were at
loggerheads over control of morocco such
a stunt may have caused an international
incident even a war the pranksters would
have likely even been shot horus
objected to the plan not for the reasons
that i just mentioned but simply because
it was too expensive the next best idea
was concocted by adrian steven a sublime
prank which went down in history as the
sultan of zanzibar hoax or the cambridge
hoax
[Music]
the plan was set in motion when adrian
found out that the sultan of zanzibar
was in london on an official visit the
pranksters set out a plan to humiliate
the mayor of cambridge a natural target
due to the ongoing rivalry between the
university and city authorities on the
2nd of march horus and adrian sent a
telegram to the mayor stating that the
sultan will arrive today at cambridge 4
27 pm for a short visit could you
arrange to show him the buildings of
interest and send a carriage signed
henry lucas colonial official horus
adrian and their friends bowen culthurst
and leland buxton disguised themselves
in durban's flowing robes fake beards
and black makeup a fifth cohort known as
drummer howard impersonated their
english interpreter whilst on the train
from london to cambridge the party
learned that the sultan himself was due
to visit buckingham palace that
afternoon thinking quickly on his feet
horace decided he would impersonate the
sultan's fictitious uncle prince
mccarcerali instead pranksters were
lavishly welcomed by the mayor and his
entourage who gifted the mcguide book to
cambridge and a bottle of champagne
horus reciprocated by donating the
dorsal fin from the sacred ark of
zanzibar the party then proceeded to
visit a local market where disaster
almost struck an elderly lady who had
been a missionary to zanzibar accosted
prince macasa and asked if she could
converse in the local language drummer
the interpreter quickly stepped in
claiming that the prince would talk to a
woman only if she joined his harem after
an official tour of the guild hall in
king's college zanzibari and dignitaries
politely declined to stay for dinner and
hastily returned to the train station
the mayor had been utterly duped and his
humiliation was complete when adrian and
horace leaked the story to their papers
on the 4th of march the daily mail
described the stunt as one of the most
audacious and carefully planned
practical jokes ever perpetrated by
undergraduates
[Music]
when cole emerged from cambridge and
into the real world he did not feel the
inclination to take up any serious
profession well any profession for that
matter and in truth he didn't really
need it in 1906 his paternal grandmother
died bequeathing him a vast estate in
her inheritance as virginia woolf wrote
and so instead of going to the bar or
becoming a man of business he made it
his business simply to make people laugh
and make them laugh he did cole launched
a series of stunts designed to baffle
and humiliate the staples of respectable
british society for example he would
attend high society gatherings with a
cow's udder hanging from his trousers
when guests took notice of what looked
like a protruding male appendage and
gasped in horror he would produce a pair
of scissors and cleanly cut it off
speaking of members on another occasion
he challenged conservative mp oliver
locker samson to a race in a busy london
street he graciously gave him a head
start but before the mp had started
running cole had slipped a golden watch
into his pockets as soon as locker
sampson started running the trickster
held a policeman and shouted stop thief
the politician suffered the humiliation
of being arrested and searched cole
frequently targeted police officers to
expose their haplessness while riding on
a cab he frequently brought along the
dummy of a nude woman when the taxi
passed near a bobby horace flung opened
the doors slammed the dummy's head onto
the road and shouted an ungrateful hussy
before driving off at high speed he
further disturbed public order when he
and a group of friends dressed as road
workers and dug a trench in piccadilly
traffic was disrupted for hours while
policemen struggled to curb the ensuing
chaos other endeavors were exquisitely
surreal with a whiff of performance art
for example once cole organized a lavish
dinner party for several guests who
didn't know each other as they were
waiting for the host introductions were
made this is when they all realized that
they had the word bottom
in their surnames on another occasion he
sabotaged a pretentious play in vogue in
london he bought several numbered
tickets and handed them out the bald men
thus strategically placed their pates
seen from the theater balconies spelled
a popular expletive a four-letter word
starting with s and ending in t cole
even took care of dotting the eye that's
amazing according to another version of
the prank there were only eight bald men
and they all sat in the same row but
each had a letter painted on the back of
their heads so that the audience could
clearly read b-o-l-l-o-c-k-s
not all his practical jokes were so well
planned sometimes called like to
improvise as a dead ringer for labor
leader ramsay mcdonald cole was
frequently mistaken for him once
spotting a group of railroad workers he
introduced himself to them as the
politician to their dismay he then
launched into a terrain against the
labor movement and the dangers of
socialism none of these pranks however
impressed public opinion as much as his
masterpiece the dreadnought hoax
in early 1910 cole was accosted by a
junior naval officer who was engaged in
a duel of pranks against the officers
the hms dreadnought pride of the royal
navy could he devise the ultimate trick
to humiliate his rivals cole happily
accepted enlisting the help of adrian
stephen adrian happened to have a
rivalry with his cousin william fisher
also an officer on the dreadnought so of
course he was gay the two devised a plan
similar to the zanzibar hoax and
assembled a team which included adrian's
sister virginia the parts were thus cast
horus would play the role of herbert
chalmanderlay from the foreign office
adrian i was the interpreter another
four friends decked themselves again in
turban's blackface and beards including
virginia to portray a retinue of
obsidian dignitaries they would be led
by assal mccarlen the supposed cousin of
emperor menelik on the 10th of february
1910 a telegram was dispatched admiral
may commander-in-chief of the home fleet
prince macklin of absinia and sweet
arrive at 4 20 pm today weymouth he
wishes to see dreadnought kindly arrange
meet them on arrival in repeat of the
cambridge adventure may and his other
high-ranking officers bent over
backwards to welcome the foreign
dignitaries giving them an extensive
tour of the state-of-the-art military
facility the absentian aristocrats
admired the resplendent uniforms and the
mighty guns of the dreadnought shouting
in praise bunga bunga and other assorted
gibberish when adrian was asked to
translate the admiral speech during the
tour he mangled some words in swahili
which were completely inappropriate
mixing them with latin and ancient greek
the admiral invited the epsinians to
dinner below deck but horus refused on
their behalf knowing that consuming food
would expose the fake beards as an
excuse he claimed that the princes could
not eat food that was not halal and even
asked if they could perform their muslim
prayers at sunset at a small detail
absinia now ethiopia is a largely
christian country and the hoaxes even
wore crucifixes the whole affair exposed
how ruling classes at the time had
little knowledge and consideration of
non-european cultures after the hoax
horus and adrian once again revealed all
the details of the press causing an
outcry public opinion sided with the
pranksters ridiculing the royal navy for
their gullibility and carelessness
admiral may was even subjected to a
parliamentary inquiry this was a time
when britain was competing for supremacy
of the seas against the german fleet and
the oaks had proven that it took only a
telegram and some costumes to expose
military secrets moreover it emerged
that may had squandered military funds
for a large purchase of white kids
gloves for the occasion
[Music]
the year after the dreadnought's success
horace's sister anne married a
well-known public figure future prime
minister neville chamberlain cole's
antics were a source of embarrassment
for jane berlin and eventually also
alienated his sister this may be why
cole took to spending less time in
london leading a debauched life in
continental europe and later in dublin
during one of his trips to ireland cole
fell in love with a young heiress denise
anne-marie joss lynch the two married on
september 30th 1918. he was 37 she was
barely 19. he later organized a
honeymoon which suitably took them to
venice on april fool's day 1919. he just
couldn't help himself instead of
enjoying the night with his young wife
horace spent hours dropping horse manure
all over saint mark's square again a
rather surreal stunt carried out only to
enjoy the look of confusion on the
venetians faces in a city notoriously
devoid of horses
where did it all come from once back in
ireland the trickster had some close
brushes with the ongoing independence
struggle with which cole agreed in
principle nonetheless he was still
perceived as a member of the english
oppressing aristocracy by the ira the
kohl's estate rafford was raided by the
republicans who stole cole's best
clothes and denise's jewels subsequently
the kohl's took residence in dublin's
shelbourne hotel where horus spent the
night's drinking with novelists and
painters while there cole claimed to
have identified and apprehended an
english spy who tried to mingle with the
republicans he declared to have him
arrested for his own good otherwise he
would have been shot cole sent the
alleged spy back to london with a
message claiming that the agent had been
caught by legendary most wanted
revolutionary michael collins word
spread that the trickster was somehow
linked to collins or possibly that he
was michael collins a dangerous rumor in
fact two days later cole was confronted
by two black and tans british members of
the local constabulary with a reputation
for brutality the two officers were
eager to cash the 5 000 pound reward for
the capture of collins cole displayed a
remarkable coolness when facing the
blackened hands unleashing a secret
weapon in his own words i produced some
whiskey and succeeded by lavish
hospitality and reducing the men to a
helpless state they staggered away
saying i was a jolly good fellow even if
i was michael collins and anyway
what was five thousand pounds to them
[Music]
in the late 1920s cole's bouts of low
malicious moods took over his playful
side this aspect may have alienated his
wife although biographer martin downer
points out that they were ill-matched
from the start he also became more
direct and vulgar in his jokes when the
almanac who's who asked him to submit
his entry coal filled in his recreation
as fornicating but with less letters he
was dutifully excluded things
deteriorated further in 1928 when cole
lost all his money in a bad investment
in canada denise took the occasion to
ask for a dissolution of their marriage
alone and almost penniless cole went on
voluntary exile in france while there on
the 31st of january 1931 he remarried
with mabel wright a scullery maid and
former model to painter augustus john on
the 16th of march 1935 cole and mabel
welcomed a baby boy tristan later a tv
director who also worked on doctor who
by the way at cole had access to the
tardis he would have turned back time to
prevent mabel from ever meeting augustus
john it turned out that mabel and the
painter had been having a long-standing
affair and augustus john well he was
actually the biological father of
tristan this apparently was the ultimate
prank that life had played on the
greatest trickster of his age
heartbroken impoverished and forgotten
horus veer cole succumbed to a heart
attack on february 26 1936 in hon fleur
northwestern france and thus ends the
story of the greatest pranksters he may
have left a wake of laughter behind him
but darkness always lurked close waiting
to pounce on him when the end approached
the destiny he had in common with many
are tricks to god like loki condemned to
imprisonment misery and torture but i
want to leave you on such a serious note
horus would not agree i will instead ask
you to post in the comments what is the
greatest prank you ever witnessed or
even better performed and as always
thank you for watching now just before
you leave today's video let me tell you
about another channel that i run called
decoding the unknown it's a show where i
take a deep dive in some of the world's
biggest mysteries from what happened to
the roanoke colonists the regular guy
who found a listening device in one of
his power strips it's always a bit of a
wild ride you can find a link to
decoding the unknown below or just
search decoding the unknown in youtube
and you will find it
[Music]